[Music]
once upon a time travel shows were
stodgy as [ __ ]
television tourism of yonder was
populated with pleasant proper people
who strolled to Chalmers Elysee is over
the beaches of Rio in order to show you
how to do pleasant proper and usually
prepackaged things but it's too easy to
be snooty about a place like this early
travel shows regarded the locals as
curiosities interaction with the hosts
was either staged or kept at a
respectable distance while finding the
ideal yacht and shopping for bargains
was paramount for this customer up until
the 1990s travel shows were mostly about
watching a trusted host sniffing his way
through fine wineries pacing through
baroque era museums lounging around
four-star hotels when do I get my
bailout and indulging in the sensual
pleasures of eating familiar fare with
the right fork at the right restaurant
and always with the right kind of people
about the time that global capitalism
put distant travel within the range of
an ambitious backpacker all that began
to change travel TV went from
advertising the lifestyles of the rich
and famous to adventure tourism for the
young and penniless shows like
globetrekker showed hosts pounding vodka
inside of private homes of the newly
opened nations of the earth while iron
curtain you wild-eyed 20-something host
happily ditched the salad forks of
France and gave you a glimpse of the
back alleys of Bangkok the hosts were
real people and so were the people they
met their travels were rough and risky
he gave the distinct impression that for
a few weeks a person of ordinary means
could live like Indiana Jones the catch
was that you had to want it so badly you
were willing to live in a rat-infested
slum to do it which for a certain kind
of traveler was half the fun but the
best by far of this new breed of
adventure travel television shows
belonged to Anthony Bourdain
Bourdain who began every show with a
parental advisory warning was ten times
snarky er than all the other hosts put
together his punk nonchalance stuck out
like a middle finger to every travel
show that had ever gone before him he
savaged overhyped celebrity chefs by
name and held in righteous contempt
every culinary fad and pompous ideology
that stood in the way of the pure
enjoyment of food I liked him
immediately everything that is good it
must be hunted down and destroyed so
their genes don't pass on the future
generations Bourdain got away with being
such an arrogant weasel because
underneath the swagger was an empathetic
guy with a big idea that's been so
widely copied it's hard to remember how
novel it once was any culture no matter
how far in can be understood through its
food and so Bourdain was equally at home
twirling spaghetti in the swankiest
restaurants of Rome and scarfing down
warthog anus with the tribes of Namibia
to eat he traveled for all the right
reasons to understand the world and
understand himself I remember sitting on
my couch in Los Angeles alone and
unemployed watching the first few
episodes of a cook store the feast sees
the flavours he described and the people
he met he made the whole world seem
alive no doubt even as he was
contemplating his own death hour after
hour I watched as he traveled to Morocco
and Japan places I had only dreamed
about visiting and I started thinking
maybe I could do that maybe I should do
that and so I did
[Music]
within a month I was on a plane to India
no sooner did my feet hit the tarmac in
Mumbai I immediately in very
self-consciously began living la vida
Bourdain
I saved rupees by living in dumps and
drug dens and I spent what I could on
the best eats that the city had to offer
legendary food stalls like paddy Mia
kebab and swanky eateries like Trishna
blew my tastebuds away cooking up dishes
that were too strong or too strange or
too spiced for the American palate in
between my Hyderabadi biriyani z' and
the manifold pleasures of the thali
plate
I broke naan bread with your mom's in
the mosques of admir $8.00
with feudal Rajasthani landlords and
dined with countless others whose lives
were unquantifiable different from my
own two weeks later I'd move on to
another city and do it all over again I
had no real plan I just kept moving at
this one I just seen my first missile
strike
it was on the airport that we'd flown
into in Beirut no reservations began as
a show about food and culture but with
the outbreak of the 2006 Lebanon War
Bourdain and his crew were forced by
circumstance to become now you were in
Beirut shooting an episode of your show
what happened I was with a Sunni Shiite
in a Christian at the time when we
started to hear gunfire and see cars
filled with hizbollah supporters the
Beirut episode of No Reservations
permanently changed the course of the
show as politics became as important as
food you sleep through but you wake up
to bombing you watch bombings in the
pool during the afternoon you go to
sleep to bomb around the time no
reservations began it's slow pivot into
politics I found myself doing the same
our top story in Nepal a government
forces fired on thousands of
pro-democracy demonstrators today for
weeks they police have protested the
country's non-party political system I
took an internship as a photojournalist
with the Katmandu post Nepal's toxic
brew of ruling monarchists insurgent
Maoists and ethically based political
alliances set the stage for the
culmination of a 15-year Civil War what
began as an adventure in food and travel
was fast becoming a life in news
photography
[Music]
t-midi solid ice yes a kosher now my
foot when the dust settled the world's
last Hindu king was forced from his
throne replaced by the violent birth of
a troubled democracy
I can't wait to get out there there
really understand what Capone accusing
is all about their main reason I'm here
is to understand the food I returned to
Los Angeles to find the television
completely bore Dana fide television had
spawned a dozen Anthony Bourdain clones
each one wandering the world in a weekly
quest for that white whale of serious
travel hosts cultural authenticity and
clicks while the snarky hosts who've got
my ass off the couch in the first place
was now a legit celebrity first time I
came here it was a transformative
experience but Bourdain's knockoffs and
clones never understood that the journey
outward was always something of a ruse
even while reporting on far-flung
conflicts Bourdain used travel and food
as vehicles for introspection show after
show
he left us clues about his state of mind
concealed inside gallows humor and
easily forgotten in the pleasures of an
exquisite meal I love this place and I
want to die you're already perfect
seaweed difficulty is just
I'm ready to die now you can't enjoy
even a nice stinky runnin ripe cheese
like this so Tony what groped you here
Bourdain's dark in her life was never
more on display than on a visit to
Argentina where he saw a local therapist
I will find myself in an airport for
instance and I'll order an airport
hamburger
it's an insignificant thing it's a small
thing it's a hamburger but it's not a
good one suddenly I look at the
hamburger and I find myself in a spiral
of depression that can last for days in
the end Anthony Bourdain couldn't be
contained by this world not by its
political or existential borders the
meal of my life
he passed through some of the world's
most dangerous places unharmed only to
turn the belt of his hotel robe into a
hangman's noose for all the books he
wrote and the shows he narrated Bourdain
left without a word of explanation so
I'm left with a sense of loss and an
enduring gratitude for the recorded
memory of a life lived spectacularly
[Music]
you